la vie c'est des moments donc c'était ce
moment qui était cool mais après il faut
pas croire que ça reste comme ça toute
la vie aujourd'hui
des fois les gens jalouse ou sont à fond
sur des gens qui sont hyper côté en ce
moment ils sont cotées aujourd'hui mais
dans 5 ans expo ou dans deux ans et ce
con ou le plus dur n'est pas d'y arriver
c'est de tenir
[Musique]
gérard soubiran foyer de baisser du
créateur c'est très important les
rencontres que tu fais quand tu es gamin
c'est ce qui permet de déclencher un
avenir sont bons pas mon entrée au foyer
ça s'est fait en j'avais 7 ans donc en
92 un truc comme ça
les services sociaux qui passe
l'été qui viennent de dire ce que ça te
dirait d'aller dans un endroit où il ya
plus d'enfants où tu seras mieux où tu
auras une chambre et tous et puis tu
taxer être le truc puisque tu te dis
ouais cool une chambre jugé dans un dans
un 12 m² avec cinq personnes ça te force
à quelqu'un parce que tu te prends à
vivre en communauté
tu apprends les règles que t'as pas chez
toi tu apprends comment ranger ta
chambre faire ton lit que des trucs
basiques comme ça que j'ai le souvenir
de moi d'un indicateur qui s'appelle
jean marc et qui avec kamal les deux
d'ailleurs remarquer gamal qui ont pris
soin de moi qui ont qui est qu'ils sont
occupés de moi qui m'ont appris la
culture qui m'ont appris l'humour même
jean marc était hyper drôle ces
rencontres là je pense qu'elles sont
très importantes pour que l'enfant
puisse s'accrocher à une référence
positive gamal par exemple c'était un
algérien et moi algérien au foyer venant
d'un milieu social pauvres je me disais
bien nous les algériens c'est comme ça
il ya que ça je pense qu'il a déteint
sur moi dans ce côté là où ce côté de
rentrer dans vie de culture dans vie de
deux que d'être à la hauteur des autres
[Musique]
à 17 ans je me suis acheté une caméra
j'avais emprunté celle d'un pote ça m'a
donné envie d'en acheter une à moi et je
faisais je faisais
en vocal en playback ça aurait pu être
des tic toc aujourd'hui des sketches des
inconnus où je me déguisais je reprenais
le les paroles des inconnus se sait les
montages avec deux domaines et aux scop
je connais un magnétoscope d'un côté
avec le sketch des inconnus l'autre et
que mon truc et je connais la voix
dessus c'était pas si t'es pas là le
déclic il s'est fait plus tard quand
j'ai commencé à faire beaucoup de vidéos
grâce à ce caméscope et j'ai fait un
téléfilm sur france 3 il s'appelle le
troisième jour il ya eu un déclic à ce
moment là mais évidemment tous ces
moments où je m'amusais avec la caméra
c'était un truc qui me rapprochait de ce
que je voulais faire
et puis dans la vie des fois il ya des
trucs qui arrive
qui sont pas calculés et qui nous montre
que la suite elle est déjà tout tracé
moi je crois beaucoup à ça on fait pas
les choses par hasard la première fois
que j'ai pu vivre de ma passion c'était
c'était ben justement le troisième jour
en fait je travaillais chez orange et je
faisais des vidéos à côté avec mon
caméscope et tout et je gagnais 2 par
mois entre est comme ça et là j'ai été
pris inopinément où je sais même pas
comment ça s'est passé
j'ai été pris pour ce téléfilm et à
partir de là quand j'arrivais sur
plateau j'ai fait auquel c'est génial et
surtout je me suis dit j'ai regardé
comment combien j'étais payé alors que
j'étais juste et personne n'a rien du
tout je faisais 1000 francs par jour et
j'ai eu 15 jours de tournage
le problème c'est que quand tu fais un
téléfilm bah c'est juste un petit rôle
dans un téléfilm et quand tu le fais en
partant de orange tu le dis c'est vrai
j'ai percé moi ça y est je fais des
films
laissez moi sauf que derrière en fait tu
n'as rien tu as rien du tout sûrs
retourne chez toi ben t'as ton salaire à
quel tu profites mais tu utilises il n'y
a pas de proposition ça se passe pas
comme ça ça se passe pas aussi
rapidement que ça et donc j'ai gardé
pendant sept ans ouais sept ans avant de
2,2 euros repourvoir vivre de ma passion
et j'ai tourné dans deux trois trucs
comme ça à droite à gauche et puis après
au gouvernement je me suis dit mais en
fait il ya personne qui va m'aider et
j'ai commencé à faire plein de vidéos
plein de vidéos plein de vidéos
j'enchaînais j'aimerais aider ça faisait
pas de vue on peut j'ai fait des vannes
mais j'aime à le rappeler c'est là que
ça a commencé à tout décoller